egal ob ihr auto fahrrad oder auch nicht
die mal wieder aktuelle diese debatte
betrifft jeden von uns denn es geht um
die luft die wir einatmen
doch jetzt kam lungenärzte mit diesem
statement daher in dem sie sinngemäß
behaupten dass die aktuellen grenzwerte
misst sein und das auch die angst vor
stickoxide und feinstaub
unwissenschaftlich sein
ihr wisst was jetzt kommt oder holt euch
und er macht es euch gemütlich den wir
gehen das hier jetzt in aller ruhe durch
[Musik]
ja ich kann mir heute leider gar keinen
tee machen da ich mich in einem
theologen hotelzimmer befinde
aber ich hoffe hier macht es euch
trotzdem gemütlich fangen wir an mit den
gesundheitlichen basics warum sind
feinstaub und stickoxide ungesund
feinstaub bezeichnet kleinste partikel
im unteren mikrometerbereich die durch
einatmen in den körper gelangen und dort
entzündungen auslösen können es gibt
primären feinstaub der entsteht direkt
durch verbrennungsprozesse oder durch
abrieb und es gibt sekundären feinstaub
der entsteht durch chemische reaktionen
landwirtschaft industrie produzieren
viel feinstaub aber eben auch verkehr
sei es durch reifenabrieb oder durch
abgase jetzt kein feinstaub
verschiedenste chemische
zusammensetzungen haben sie sind weniger
entscheidend als die partikelgröße denn
je kleiner desto gefährlicher kann man
sagen
ab einer größe von 2,5 mikrometer
abwärts wird es besonders gefährlich man
bezeichnet diese partikel als pm2 5 p m
steht für partikel etter feinstaub kann
das risiko für schlaganfälle und
herzinfarkte erhöhen
mit dem portfolio sind außer dem lohn
krebs asthma allergien und generelle
atembeschwerden
da die stickoxide stickoxide sind gase
die bei verbrennungen entstehen zum
beispiel in industrieanlagen heizanlagen
oder eben auch in automotoren in städten
kommen 60 prozent der stickoxide aus
verkehrs abgas genau genommen sind es
gase nämlich stickstoffmonoxid eno und
stickstoffdioxid no2 werden oft
zusammengefasst unter nx habt ihr
vielleicht auch schon gehört beide gase
entstehen bei autoabgasen nur wird es
ziemlich stellt in no2 umgewandelt
weswegen no2 das relevantere gas von
beiden ist und dieses gas ist mehrfach
problematisch ist zunächst giftig und
ätzend und kann lungen schäden
verursachen eine langfristige aussetzung
kann aber auch zu chronischen und
allergischen atemwegserkrankungen führen
und lebt sich auch auf die
gesamtsterblichkeit aus doch auch die
chemische reaktion von no2 sind
problematisch mit wasser reagiert es zu
salpetersäure das schade böden und
gewässern
es kann auch ozon bilden also wurden da
ist schon was auch nicht so toll ist und
es kann zum beispiel ammoniumnitrat
bilden das in form von feinsten
partikeln also feinstaub die luft
verschmutzt das heißt no2 ist auch ein
so genanntes vorläufer gas für feinstaub
tja und diesel autos stoßen besonders
viel stickoxide aus viel näher als
benziner
viele politische fragen eine
wissenschaftliche grundlage
hier ist also hier ist kein thema wie
willst alle politischen debatten
basieren auf einer wissenschaftlichen
grundlage nämlich dass die stickstoff-
und feinstaub konzentrationen die wir
jetzt hier auf den straßen einatmen
gesundheitsschädlich sind
wenn sie das nicht wäre müssten wir auch
nicht über diesel fahrverbote
diskutieren und genau bei dieser basis
greift jetzt dieses statement ein
denn hierin heißt es dass die grenzwerte
die derzeit in deutschland gelten nicht
gerechtfertigt sein
und das ist deswegen auch keinen
handlungsbedarf gebe
solange diese grenzwerte nicht neu
bestimmt werden das schreibt professor
dieter köhler und drei weitere autoren
das sind zwei ärzte und zwei ingenieure
und sie werden unterstützt durch eine
unterschriftenliste von rund 100 profs
und doktoren die medien stürzten sich
auf dieses statement und dieter köhler
wurde bisher schon in viele
öffentlich-rechtliche talkshows und
nachrichten
eingeladen und unser
bundesverkehrsminister andreas scheuer
sagte der aufruf der lungenärzte muss
dazu führen dass die umsetzung der
grenzwerte hinterfragt und
gegebenenfalls verändert wird und dass
er sich freue dass sich so viele
experten zusammengeschlossen haben um
noch mal fakten in die debatte zu
bringen und damit eine versachlichung
ich brauchte gehen wir erstmal durch die
stellungnahme absatz für absatz und ab
geht die party die stellungnahme beginnt
mit einem paar ergebnissen aus der
bisherigen forschung und ein paar zahlen
daraus in abschnitt zwei werden diese
zahlen in frage gestellt denn
schließlich sehen die lungenärzte in
ihren praxen und kliniken todesfälle an
copd da steht für chronisch obstruktive
lungenkrankheit und lungenkrebs täglich
jedoch tote durch feinstaub und nx auch
bei sorgfältiger anamnese lni eine
anamnese ist eine professionelle
medizinische befragung das klar dass man
so sachen wie rauchen besser
nachvollziehen kann als
luftverschmutzung wie viel rauchen sie
im schnitt pro tag drei bis vier
zigaretten und wie viel stickoxid achten
sie so ein
natürlich kann man stattdessen fragen ob
die person zum beispiel an einer viel
befahrenen straße gut trotzdem verrät so
eine info einem jungen arzt nicht so
viel wie etwa die anzahl der zigaretten
ein raucher an gibt denn ein lungenkrebs
patient ist mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit
von 85 prozent raucher weil man durchs
rauchen einfach so hohe konzentrationen
an schädlichen stoffen inhalte perfekt
ist so stark dass auch ein lohn arzt in
seiner kleinen praxis deutlich sehen
kann dass ein zusammenhang zwischen
rauchen und lungenkrebs besteht im
gegensatz dazu wird bei
luftverschmutzung also bei den
konzentrationen von stickoxiden und
feinstaub über libyen
das krankheitsrisiko deutlich weniger
wir haben hier viel geringere
konzentrationen aber dafür ständig und
über einen sehr langen zeitraum direkte
sind so klein dass ein normal
praktizierender lungenarzt das in seiner
praxis mit was ich ein paar hundert
patienten nicht sehen wird also es wird
nämlich auffallend fazit natürlich sehen
sie keine feinstaub toten weil man sie
als praktizierender lungenarzt auch gar
nicht sehen kann
deswegen schaut man sich viel größere
gruppen von menschen über einen viel
längeren zeitraum an
in sogenannten epidemiologischen studien
und genau diese studien werden in diesem
statement jetzt kritisiert so absatz 3
geht's jetzt los
hier steht die studien hätten einen
systematischen fehler was die autoren
kritisieren sind die so genannten
methoden dieser studien also die art und
weise der datenerhebung und der
auswertung das ist prinzipiell ein
wichtiger punkt und wenn ihr meinen
kanal schon länger schaut dann wisst ihr
vielleicht auch schon das
wissenschaftliche ergebnisse wenig
aussagen solange ihr nicht wisst wie
diese ergebnisse entstanden sind also
wie sind die ergebnisse über feinstaub
und stickoxid entstand ein klassisches
studiendesign wäre eine so genannte
kohortenstudie bei einer kohortenstudie
nehme ich eine möglichst große gruppe
von menschen die zum beispiel an
verschieden stark befahrenen straßen
wohnen das was ich stadtmenschen wird
das land menschen dann beobachte ich
diese menschen jahrelang oder
jahrzehntelang und schaue ob diejenigen
die jetzt mehr stickoxide oder mehr
feinstaub ausgesetzt sind über die jahre
auch häufige krankheiten entwickeln oder
ob sie früher sterben als ihre
lebenserwartung werde und hier kommen
wir zu kritikpunkt 1 korrelation und
kausalität beispiel ja sagen wir in
der orden studie beobachte ich dass
menschen die an stark befahrenen straßen
leben im schnitt früher sterben
außerdem sind menschen an stark
befahrenen straßen mehr feinstaub
ausgesetzt dann kann der feinstaub
ursache für das frühe stern sein muss
aber nicht denn an viel befahrenen
straßen gibt es ja auch mehr
luftverschmutzung also falsch außerdem
kann es sein dass menschen die in der
city leben ein generell stressiges leben
führen
oder vielleicht brauchen menschen in
städten mehr oder trinken mehr alkohol
weiß bei einer kohortenstudie kommen
also immer mehrere faktoren zusammen und
deswegen kann man immer nur
korrelationen feststellen also dinge die
zusammen auftreten aber keine
kausalitäten also ursache
wirkungsbeziehungen und das kritisieren
köhler und kollegen sie sagen
korrelationen sind keine kausalitäten
und damit sie auch erstmal rechts aber
sie gehen weiter und sagen korrelationen
diene nur der hypothesen bildung sie
sind nikon firma tores und das stimmt so
nicht
ich kann das so pauschal nicht sagt ich
muss immer schauen wie nah korrelation
und kausalität zusammenliegen
in manchen fällen haben sie gar nichts
miteinander zu tun zum beispiel
korreliert die anzahl der todesfälle
durch ertrinken im pool mit der anzahl
der nicolas cage filme aber korrelation
und kausalität können auch sehr nah
beieinander liegt das habe ich hier auch
schon mal erklärt und trotzdem wäre es
falsch zu sagen dass man mit
korrelationen keine ursachen erschließen
kann bei zucker und diabetes typ 2 zum
beispiel gibt es inzwischen so viele
verschiedene studien die sich
gegenseitig bestätigen und die
einhergehen mit allem was wir über den
zuckerstoffwechsel wissen und
herausgefunden haben so dass man mit
gutem gewissen sagen kann ein hoher
zuckerkonsum begünstigt diabetes typ 2
hasse ich jetzt damit sagen korrelation
ist nicht automatisch gleich kausalität
aber korrelation ist auch nicht
automatisch ungleich kausalität
man muss also von fall zu fall
entscheiden
und im fall stickoxide und im fall
feinstaub sind sich die experten einig
dass die summe der daten eine
gesundheitsschädlichkeit klar belegt und
zwar nicht nur belegt durch
korrelationen ausgehalten studien
sondern zum beispiel auch durch
sogenannte toxikologische studien also
experimente mit zähnen oder mit ihren
mann die gesundheitsschädliche wirkung
auch bio mechanistisch ziemlich genau
nachvollziehen kann az entweder haben
die lungenärzte korrelation und
kausalität nicht richtig verstanden
oder sie stellen es bewusst einseitig da
zweitens störfaktoren schreiben hier
ganz richtig und das haben wir gerade
auch schon angeschnitten die
krankheitshäufigkeit und die
lebenserwartung werden durch zahlreiche
faktoren bestimmt beispiel ich vergleich
jetzt menschen die in der stadt leben
und menschen die auf dem land leben
jetzt haben die menschen der stadt mehr
luftverschmutzung hat sie auf dem land
dafür haben die menschen auf dem land
zum beispiel auch mehr bewegung und die
bewegung gibt sich ja auch positiv auf
deren gesundheit aus und das muss ich
berücksichtigen wenn mir das bewusst ist
und nicht die bewegung ebenfalls
beobachte dann kann ich das in meiner
datenauswertung sinnvoll rausrechnen
köhler und chor sagen hierzu ein
sogenanntes adjustieren der einflüsse in
den studien durch fragebögen ist
wissenschafts methodologische nicht
zulässig übersetzt heißt das dieses
rausrechnen ist methodisch nicht korrekt
und man sollte es deswegen lassen weil
es die realität zu sehr verzerrt und
manchmal stimmt das auch genau das
problem hatten wir zum beispiel bei
unserem video über alkohol wo die
abstinenzler also die gar kein alkohol
tranken sich so stark von den anderen
unterschieden dass man sie nicht mehr
sinnvoll in die auswertung mit rein
nehmen konnte aber mit einem guten
studiendesign kann man versuchen solche
dinge zu vermeiden indem man zum
beispiel die studienteilnehmer so
ausgewählt dass sie möglichst viel
gemeinsam haben und die studien auf die
sich unsere offiziellen grenzwerte
beziehen
die sind ordentlich design auch die
behauptung dass lebensstil und
gesundheitsbewusstsein nicht erfasst
werden
stimmt nicht so ganz denn zum beispiel
erfasst man sehr oft den
sozioökonomischen status der zu
sehr viel wert über
gesundheitsbewusstsein und lebensstil
fazit wohlbekannte herausforderungen für
die es gängige methoden gibt werden hier
fälschlicherweise zu einem
systematischen und unlösbaren fehler
aufgebauscht damit machen die
lungenärzte den gesamten fachbereich der
epidemiologie schlecht wobei sie selbst
wohlgemerkt fachfremd sind es stecke
lungenarzt planning quasi drittens
schwellenwert und toxizität musste hier
verstehe ich die argumentation ich kann
sie sagen bei stickoxiden und feinstaub
gibt es keinen schwellenwert also keine
konzentration bei der sie ungefährlich
wären
und das stimmt es gilt stattdessen
einfach je mehr desto höher das risiko
ich kann nur sagen die offiziellen
grenzwert die sind natürlich eine
politische abwägung unsere gesundheit
auf der einen seite und machbarkeit und
kosten auf der anderen seite und die
höhe des grenzwertes hier im fall
feinstaub und stickoxide die hängt von
machbarkeit und kosten ab denn rein
gesundheitlich betrachtet jetzt
passenderweise der krankenwagen seien
gesundheitlich gilt hier
je weniger luftverschmutzung desto
besser punkt im nächsten abschnitt sagen
sie sei stark und nx die haben kein
typisches charakteristisches
krankheitsbild wie zum beispiel rauchen
und lungenkrebs oder raucherbein sondern
es sind viele verschiedene krankheiten
und sie sagen weil es hier kein
typisches vergiftungs muster gibt
spricht das gegen eine gefährdung zu
dieser argumentation überzeugt mich
jetzt überhaupt nicht denn keine ahnung
bewegungsmangel hat auch kein typisches
krankheitsbild sondern begünstigt eine
ganze vielzahl von krankheiten genau
dasselbe bei schlafmangel motto wir auch
noch ein ganzes video haben zu nehmen
fazit ein schwellenwert sowie ein
typisches krankheitsbild sind keine
voraussetzung für einen anerkannten
giftstoff durch wird das hier
fälschlicherweise so dargestellt
nächste station so jetzt kommt ihr
stärkstes argument die sagen
zigarettenrauch enthält ja unmengen mehr
stickoxide und feinstaub als
ich jetzt auf der straße einatmen und
darüber hinaus ja noch viel mehr andere
schädliche stoffe
das stimmt das heißt sie sagen jetzt
hier werden ein raucher x-mal soviel
stickoxide inhaliert wie ich jetzt auf
der straße
dann müssten raucher ja auch x-fach
früher sterben und auch ihren eigenen
berechnungen die jetzt hier nicht näher
aufgeschlüsselt sind müssten die meisten
raucher nach wenigen monaten alle
versterben was offensichtlich nicht der
fall
update inzwischen ist rausgekommen dass
hier ein rechenfehler vorliegt es wäre
nicht ein paar monate sondern ein paar
jahre und dieter köhler diesen
rechenfehler auch schon eingeräumt und
sagt das ändert aber nichts an der
tatsache und da gebe ich ihm recht denn
das eigentliche problem steckt ganz
woanders um dem zu entgehen klar ich mir
mal hier ein ausschnitt von meinen
kollegen bei tera xoxo war da wo das
schon perfekt beantwortet das risiko
flacht ab
ein raucher der 100 zigaretten raucht im
vergleich zu jemanden der eine zigarette
raucht am tag hat ja auch nicht 100 fach
erhöhtes risiko und so ähnlich ist es
auch in bezug auf das passivrauchen das
heißt auch in innenräumen kann auch zum
beispiel herzinfarkte auslösen aber da
ist das risiko 50 prozent erhöht während
ein raucher 100 fach erhöhtes 100
erhöhtes risiko hat und wenn man das
jetzt runter sieht auf den feinstaub
dann ist das risiko insgesamt kleiner
aber dem feinstaub sind wir stark und
macht ausgesetzt und auch alle
bevölkerungsgruppen
fazit die x-fache konzentration führt
eben nicht zu einem x-fach früheren
sterben ein solcher linearer
zusammenhang besteht hier überhaupt
nicht die rechnung der lungen erster ist
also schlicht und einfach in
grundprinzip falsch rechenfehler hin
oder her so viel zum stärksten argument
dass es kann gut sein dass ich als
erwachsener gesunder mensch auch höhere
konzentrationen von feinstaub und
stickoxid problemlos wegstecken
aber es gibt ja auch noch kinder auf
unsere straßen und ältere und menschen
die bereits lungen oder atemprobleme
haaren und wenn es um die luft geht da
draußen dann müssen wir die schwächsten
die gesundheitlich schwächsten in
unserer gesellschaft unbedingt schützen
denn wir haben ja alle keine wahl wir
müssen ja alle atmen
deswegen finde ich strenge grenzwerte
bei luftverschmutzung richtig so das
statement endet mit einer ziemlich und
verschiedene unterstellung sie fordern
nämlich eine neubewertung der
wissenschaftlichen studien durch
unabhängige forscher damit wird er
impliziert dass die forscher bisher
nicht unabhängig waren was eine freche
unterstellung ist für die hier noch
nicht mal begründungen geliefert werden
das sind keine experten hier das sind
100 menschen ziemlich
unwissenschaftliche aussagen
unterschrieben haben und die stehen
gegen tausende expertinnen und experten
doch im tor schoss kriegt man dann den
eindruck hier steht aussage gegen
aussage
falls balance nennt man das ich finde
das geht gar nicht und deswegen und ihr
wisst ich bitte euch nicht auf warum
aber dieses mal bitte teilt dieses video
denn so ein unwissenschaftliche unfug
darf nicht einfach so akzeptiert werden
das war jetzt wie gesagt die
wissenschaftliche basis feinstaub und
stickoxid das ist nicht cool wollen wir
reduzieren
wie man jetzt die konkret reduziert und
ob diesel fahrverbote dabei wirklich
helfen
das sind nochmal ganz andere fragen und
diese fragen werden wir am mittwoch bei
maischberger diskutieren also wenn
dieses video rauskommt dann war ich
schon bei maischberger das thema war
diese grenzwerte fahrverbote
ich werde euch den link zur mediathek in
die video beschreibung packen und weiß
ihr große freunde der sonne seite und
nicht verpassen wollte wenn ich mal im
fernsehen bin ich bin ja zum beispiel
auch bei quarks dann
könnt ihr mir bei instagram oder twitter
folgen dann kündige ich so was auch
immer an dann fahrt ihr das auch
rechtzeitig wir sehen uns nächste woche
bis dahin bleibt sicher